we got the the the two big dogs the
eagle right here
what is in the future of eagle obviously
the tours the uh he just told me he's
not announcing the tours yet but they're
coming yeah the album's finally here
uh but as a company he just told me
about the new artist i think you had
mentioned him before
um
how many artists are you guys trying to
sign is it gonna be like uh we're gonna
just work one at a time develop you know
are you guys always scouting for talent
like what's what's next for eagle um i
mean honestly i think that we're kind of
treating it just the same way we
treating black's career
it's kind of like as we examine every
step rather than taking that elevator
you know you don't really get to see the
floors when you're on the elevator just
tell you what number you at
when we on these stairs we get to
examine every stair and then we kind of
react based off of what's kind of given
to us you know so right now we're kind
of like in a cause and effect space at
this moment we're not like oh we got to
like pinpoint these 10 artists more so
like okay we're going to go with the
flow and actually what works and what's
mutually beneficial for the company and
the artist
what about you bless what's like
something you're looking for in an
artist when it comes to like
putting your arm around them you know
what i mean because i feel like not a
lot of people are built like you and
they sure the [ __ ] don't got your work
ethic or your
just i mean talk about
you know
longevity you've been doing this for so
long you stayed down until it really
worked out a lot of people aren't built
like that so yeah that's definitely what
i look for like mostly talented like jay
millie and he know how to play every
instrument damn near
and he write produce record himself so
[ __ ] like that is what i'm inspired by
so if i'm not inspired by you then i
wouldn't even want to work with you in
the first place i feel like too it's
important that artists also kind of
self-manage themselves a bit right vic
because it's like you don't want to have
to like hold someone's hand through
every aspect of life 100
i was just telling them yesterday like
um i'm very spoiled in my business
practice at this point because
we don't got to outsource that much and
a lot of stuff that blast needs to take
care of if there is something that pops
up like last minute whether it be a
graphic whether it be screen graphics in
the back for tour
you can kind of look to it's not even
kind of he can look to himself to
complete it if it's something that needs
to be done last minute you know what i
mean um even down to recording himself
and making sure that we got fast
turnaround coming back to different
artists whether it be the nazis or the
rick ross's people just coming in
tapping in for different features it's
easier just in communication and
efficiency